Dating is weird.
There’s flowers, chocolates, and promises
you don’t intend to keep.
But humans aren’t even the weirdest when
it comes to love in the wild.
Hey lovers, Julia here for DNews
To paraphrase the comedian Aziz Ansari, our
courtship rituals ARE WEIRD.
I mean if we like a person, we turn to them
and say “hey you know this hanging out thing
we’re doing?
Let's do this until one of us is dead.
Also, wear this piece of metal and carbon
on your finger so everyone else knows we have
an arrangement”.
But we aren’t alone in the animal kingdom
when it comes to weird romance.
Oh no.
In the wild, lots of times it’s the male
who is competing for female attention.
Usually males strut their stuff by displaying
colorful markings, performing fanciful dances,
and or even by fighting with another male.
All to say “look at me!
I’ve got the best genes!
MATE WITH ME!”
But how does a pretty tail mean good genes?
Well, sexual selection sometimes means the
flashiest animal is the fittest.
It’s when animals evolved traits to attract
a mate.
I mean take a look at the peacock, probably
the most famous example.
The males have these huge, pretty, but useless
tails.
They aren’t good for anything other than
putting on a good show.
But, the female peacocks think, because the
male is able to devote precious resources
and time to a rather useless appendage and
behavior, he must be in pretty good shape
and have pretty good genes.
Over time many animals evolved a little oddly
because of sexual selection.
There’s lots examples of odd courting behavior
in nature.
But I’ll just focus on my favorite three.
There’s the weird and wonderful hooded seal.
For hooded seals, size matters.
To entice a passing lady, male hooded seals
inflate a giant red balloon-like hood out
of their left nostril and wave it around.
According to a study published in the Canadian
Journal of Zoology seals also use these hoods
to produce calls and noises!
Usually these noises are to ward off a potential
adversary, but 12% of the time, they’re
to woo a lady seal.
Besides the best call, the male with the biggest
hood, gets the girl.
But if we’re going to talk about sexual
selection, we have to talk about birds.
Birds man, birds are the best at flashy courting.
Kind of similar to hooded seals male frigatebirds,
a tropical bird, have these huge red pouches
on their chests called a gular sac.
During mating season, the sac is bright red.
And the males gather in large groups of up
to 30 individuals.
The females fly over the group and the males
inflate their pouches and use their beaks
to drum on it to attract a mate flying over
head.
In a study published in the journal The Condor,
researchers found that the drumming on the
pouches helps to tell the females about the
size of the pouch since the angle and distance
might make it hard to see.
Once the female picks her lucky guy, she swoops
down and joins him.
He takes her beak in his and they walk off
into the sunset.
But my favorite courtship ritual might be
the bower bird.
The males of this Australian avian build elaborate
structures to seduce a female.
Often the structure, or bower, is made of
intertwining twigs and sticks.
Sometimes the structure resembles a little
hut with an opening.
And out on the front lawn of this little hut,
the bird collects things.
Lots of bright or shiny items.
It’s a garden of buttons or bottle caps
or flowers.
All this building and collecting takes up
precious time he could have spent hunting
or foraging for food, but they pay off is
pretty great.
A female bird will come and sit in his bower
and watch as the male performs a complex dance.
If she doesn’t like it, or finds him lacking
in some way she’ll check out the bird next
door.
But sometimes the grass isn’t always greener
on the other side.
She could come back... once she checks out
a few places, she picks the one she likes
best.
Picking the one you like best is always hard
choice, but the animal kingdom makes it a
little easier with things like flashy tails.
While we might not have a gular sac or nasal
hood, there is always the tradition of giving
jewelry.
Speaking of, special thanks to Kay Jewelers
for sponsoring this episode.
For the bowerbird, every kiss begins a button
or bottle cap, for us humans, every kiss begins
with Kay.
So courting is just the first step to making
future generations of seals and birds.
And every species seems to have their own
strategy to making the beast with two backs.
Some animals even mate to the death!
To get the sexy suicidal scoop, check out
this episode from Crystal.